protein protein protein this guy so you
got like 30 35 grams of protein in this
so this whole thing has 110 grams of
protein there's also these core Powers
this is 42 grams per person with 230
calories tuna Creations 17 grams of
protein no carbs basically no fat almost
pure protein ham and turkey is not bad
so there's a four count in here 560
calories and 32 grams of protein hello
sir so the biggest most expensive item
on this thing was this which ended up
being 20 bucks so with this turkey sub
all I would really do here is Rip this
Center out toss the the breads on the
outside but if I were going pure
efficiency on a dollars to protein basis
I'd be going tuna packets and this guy
got 106 calories here with 34 grams of
protein we got 230 with 42. so all in
these were three bucks each so this is
six and then my power thing was four ten
dollar lunch 400 calories 76 grams of
protein Mosey meals we out